[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARL: And I would like to
introduce today Dean Buonomano.
He is a computational
neuroscientist from UCLA.
And today he'll
talk about his book,
"Your Brain is a
Time Machine," which
you can actually buy at a
discounted price at this table.
And without further
ado, welcome Dean.
[APPLAUSE]
DEAN BUONOMANO: Thank you, Carl.
And thank you all
for coming today.
It's a pleasure to be here.
So I'd like to talk
a bit about time
and the brain and the brain
in the nature of time.
And to get my talk
started, I'd like
to start by creating
a awkward silence.
And I'd like to do that
to make three points.
The first is that your
brain is automatically
attempting to predict
what is about to happen.
Your brain is a
prediction machine.
So right there you
were trying to predict
what was about to happen.
Maybe you were thinking, uh-oh,
he's having an absent seizure.
Number two, your brain is
automatically telling time.
The only reason you
could notice that pause
is because you're creating
a temporal expectation
of the normal average
pause between words.
And that temporal
pause was violated
and that's when the passage of
time came to your attention.
And that's my
point number three.
You probably became aware
of the passage of time.
The subjective feeling
of time going slowly
because it was a slightly
awkward moment and time
probably seemed
to be going slowly
and, hopefully, it wasn't
as long as it seemed to be.
At least I hope it
wasn't, because to me it
seemed like a full minute.
But before we delve in
to the mechanisms of how
the brain tells time and the
meaning of the nature of time,
let me already start
off by pointing out
that I've used the word time
a number of times in this talk
already.
And I assume you
know what I mean.
And you assume I know
what the word means.
But is that the case?
Can we actually define time?
It turns out that the word
time is the most common noun
in the English language,
along with two others that are
units of time, year and day.
So this is an obvious
indication of how important
time is in our lives.
But it's a bit ironic
that the most common noun
in the English language is one
that we really can't define.
It's a bit embarrassing,
actually, isn't it?
So this brings us to the
problem, how do we define time?
And people have struggled with
this for a long, long time.
So 1,600 years ago,
St. Augustine said,
"What then is time?
If no one asks me,
I know what it is.
If I wish to explain it to
him who asks, I do not know."
1,600 years later, the great
physicist, Richard Feynman,
who's not one to give
up easily on problems,
basically gave up and said,
"Maybe it's just as well if we
face the fact that time is one
of those things we probably
cannot define.
What matters anyways is
not how we define time,
but how we measure it."
But it was probably the
author Douglas Adams
that gave us the most
important definition of time.
"Time is an illusion,
lunchtime doubly so."
So part of the problem is
that the word time really
means different things, right?
And let me give you this
rather contrived sentence
to make that point.
Einstein's talk on the nature
of time started on time
but seemed to last a long time.
OK, so first the
nature of time, so that
refers to the physics of time.
Is time a full blown dimension,
as in the four dimensions
of time?
Does only the present exist?
Is time a abstraction
that we scientists
use to help us
understand the universe?
Second, started on
time, that's clock time.
That's the easiest
time to define, right?
That's time as defined
as what clocks tell.
As circular as
that definition is,
it's a really useful one and
probably the most important
in that it got all
of us here on time.
The last one is the
subjective feeling of time.
So it seemed to
last a long time.
And that's tightly linked to
the problem of consciousness.
So in that sense, the
subjective sense of time
is also a very difficult
problem to address.
Now starting with
the first question,
time is really important
to how the brain works.
And this is why I
consider, in many ways,
the brain to be, if you
will, a time machine.
And there's four
reasons for that.
The brain is a machine
that tells time.
The brain generates
the subjective feeling
of the passage of time.
The brain attempts to
predict the future.
The brain remembers the past
in order to predict the future.
And finally, the brain allows
us to mentally project ourselves
into the past or the
future, something we
call Mental Time Travel.
And this is really
important for our ability
to interact with
the world, in terms
of what makes humans
unique is our ability
to engage in mental time travel.
And we'll talk a
bit more about this.
But first, consider
the first issue here,
the brain is a time machine.
So the brain tells time
across 12 orders of magnitude,
from microseconds at the lower
end over there to down here,
which you're using right
now, for sound localization.
So your brain picks up
the tens or hundreds
of micro-seconds delays
it takes sound to arrive
from my left ear to my right
ear by picking up the delta t's,
the relative time delays there.
Time perception and
speech, on the order
of hundreds of
milliseconds and seconds,
music, motor coordination
is happening on this range
of time perception.
And we'll delve more into that.
And then we have
time estimation,
which is sort of what most
people think of when we
talk about their sense of time.
How long has this
talk been lasting?
How long has the red light
been waiting to change?
And so forth.
And finally, you have
your circadian rhythms
that everybody is
familiar with, in terms
of controlling your clock,
when to get up in the morning,
and when to go to bed.
So how does the brain tell time?
So to answer that question, it's
useful to think about timing
in these different scales.
So for example, in language,
a couple of examples
here are if I say something
like, they gave her cat food
or they gave her cat food.
So there you're using
the pause in speech
to determine the
meaning of the sentence.
And by the way,
this is something
that artificial speech systems
still struggle with a bit.
This is one of the
challenges and it's
the cause of some
of the mistakes
that are still made, even with
the most advanced systems.
Now another example
here is in music.
And now I'm going to play
to you a piece of music.
And the task here is it's
a hybrid piece of music
and see if it reminds
you of anything.
But the time has been altered.
And I know some of you
were here at the beginning
and you probably saw
the next slide here.
So you're going
have to keep quiet.
But Google, please
play music here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So does this remind you of any
piece of music you know of?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So I'll give you a hint.
You guys are a
young crowd but it's
from a group called the Beatles.
Does it remind anybody, does
that ring a bell to anybody?
Can anybody pick
up what that was?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yellow Submarine.
DEAN BUONOMANO: OK, very good.
Anything else?
Anybody else, does it remind
you of any other song?
So that's a hybrid song there.
So what that was was
the notes, so you
were paying more attention
to the notes, the melody,
of Yellow Submarine, but it
was the timing of Yesterday.
So we sort of did
a hybrid crossing
of the spatial information
and the temporal information.
So sometimes people
pick up a bit more
on the temporal structure,
sometimes people
pick up more on the melody.
But this is just to
make the obvious point
that, without time and ability
to perceive and tell time,
music, of course,
wouldn't exist.
And indeed, it's in
this scale of tens
to hundreds of milliseconds
that time is most important.
So in the context of
the lab, for example,
one question we ask is
whatever the mechanisms
within your brain that
allow you to tell time,
can they improve with practice?
So we often ask
in studies, where
we do an internal
discrimination studies,
to tell us is the first or
second interval the longest?
Google, please play music.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So there's a simple interval
discrimination task.
And the question is, was
the first or second longest?
And the first was
100 milliseconds
and the second interval
was 150 milliseconds.
Now, if you have some
timer in your brain
that's fixed like a watch,
maybe it doesn't matter.
Maybe you can't
get better at that.
But if you practice and
that timer improves,
then you should be
able to pick that up.
And we do.
And we can tell here that in
the 100 millisecond case, that's
what you just heard,
people improve dramatically
with practice.
But interestingly, if you
had a clock in your brain
that was your master
clock, and that clock
with somehow improving,
you should get better
at all intervals.
So you should also get better
at the 50 millisecond interval,
the 200 millisecond interval,
or the 500 millisecond.
But you don't.
So this is a bit strange.
It's almost as if you have
multiple clocks in your brain.
You have an array
of different clocks
that can tell time across
different time ranges.
So how does the brain do that?
Or what parts of the brain
are responsible for time?
Fortunately, we know exactly
what part of the brain
tells time.
And that's this part
right here, right
beside locality and music,
conveniently located.
This, of course, is nonsense.
But this phrenological
view of time,
nevertheless, is surprisingly
influential in how
people think about time.
So people do still think
about time, even today,
in the sense that you might have
a central clock in your brain.
So the office of this
faculty is to mark
the passage of time,
duration, succession
of events, et cetera.
It also remembers dates,
keeps correct time
in music and
dancing, and induces
to punctuality in the
fulfillment of engagement.
So this is an
extreme view of what
you'd call a central clock, or
a master clock, in your brain.
We know that this
is not correct.
The brain has multiple
ways to tell time,
has multiple areas
in the brain that
are involved in telling time.
To understand how
the brain tells time,
let's first remind ourselves how
man-made clocks actually work.
So man-made clocks,
despite their complexity,
all work, for the most part,
on an embarrassingly simple
principle.
And that's just an oscillator,
your time base, and a counter.
So whether you're talking about
a pendulum clock or a quartz
crystal or even an atomic
clock, in which you're
using the period of the
electromagnetic vibrations
to tell time,
you're just counting
the ticks of an oscillator.
So it's reasonable to ask, is
that how the brain tells time?
The answer is no.
So as this quote from
Einstein reminds us,
"Any physical
phenomenon may be used
as a clock provided it can be
exactly repeated as many times
as desired."
So here we have raindrops
falling on a pond.
And if I asked you, which
raindrop fell first, that one
over here or down here?
You could tell me this
raindrop fell first.
And if we were so inclined
and knew a bit of physics,
we could even
calculate the interval.
So the point is that
even this static image
has information about time.
And that's because physical
systems that have dynamics
naturally tell time.
I mean, that's essentially
what dynamics is.
Dynamics is the change in time.
So the idea is that the
brain uses its own dynamics
as one way to tell time.
So neurons are the computation
element of the brain.
And neurons have their dendrites
and their axons down here.
The axons of one
neuron can come over
and synapse on the
dendrites of another neuron.
And that's where
they make a synapse.
It releases transmitter here and
creates a bioelectrical signal
that travels towards the soma
of the post-synaptic nerve.
So if you have these
elements and they're
connected to each other, one
way we could make a timer
or a clock, if you will, is
to connect them in a chain.
So if we had one neuron that
was connected to another,
connected to another,
we can now see
that we'll have this
temporal pattern of activity
in which one neuron activates
the next, activates the next,
activates the next.
So you know that, if
this neuron is active,
that eight or nine time
units have elapsed.
So indeed, it seems that
one way the brain tells
time on the scale of tens
to hundreds of milliseconds
to seconds is through
neural dynamics.
And we know this in
part due to research
on a number of studies, on
both humans and animals.
And one animal that knows how
to time very well are songbirds.
So these are zebra
finches and they sing.
And I won't play
you their song here,
but this is the spectrogram
of a zebra finch song.
And not too different
from speech,
in which this is our frequency
axis, this is, of course, time,
and these are the
syllables of the song,
and they can sing this hundreds
and hundreds of times pretty
faithfully, where you
could almost overlay
each song on top of each other.
When scientists record from
neurons in an area of the zebra
finch brain, they can record
from many different neurons.
So here they're recording
from 136 neurons.
And here we're just
showing the activity
when those neurons spike
and aligning them in time.
And so some neurons
spike early on,
some neurons spike
later, and so forth.
So you have sort of
this chain of activity
in which seems to be the brain's
clock, for the song at least.
So some neurons
telling, OK, it's
beginning of the song, middle
of the song, and so forth.
So you have these complex
patterns, it's neural dynamics.
Now in a more complex network,
and this is a simulation here,
and normally I wouldn't
show this simulation,
but here because I'm
at Google and there's
a strong interest in AI
and machine learning,
I'll give you an
example of a simulation
of a recurrent neural
network in which you're
simulating neurons.
And these neurons are
connected to each other.
And actually, Carol,
I forgot, there's
one more button I'm
going to have to ask
Google to press in a minute.
And when you do
this, this network
is going to do a speech
recognition task, a speech
transcription task.
So the network will
listen to a spoken digit
and then transcribe
that pattern in time.
So, Google, can you
start that movie please?
So what you'll see here,
I'll show a point over here.
COMPUTER: Two.
DEAN BUONOMANO: So
that's the spectrogram.
And this is the activity
in the neural network.
So this is the activity
of different neurons.
And this is driving
the activity.
COMPUTER: Five.
DEAN BUONOMANO: And the
activity here is driving.
So there's not much hidden here.
Unlike, say, a deep
learning network,
which drives a lot of
serious power, of course.
COMPUTER: Nine.
DEAN BUONOMANO: This
is the whole thing
happening right here.
This network is driving this
and processing this stimulus.
There's around
4,000 units in this.
And it's contrast
to a deep network
in which you have millions.
COMPUTER: Eight.
DEAN BUONOMANO: So
that was in fast eight
and the next eight
will be slower.
COMPUTER: Eight.
DEAN BUONOMANO: So that
was a slower eight.
And the point here is
that by encoding time
in these trajectories,
in the dynamics
of these neural networks,
it naturally solves
the problem of what we call
temporal invariants, the issue
of how you can recognize
a song or speech,
whether it's spoken very
quickly or very slowly.
So overall, as far
as we know, one
of the major
computational strategies
the brain has to process time
varying information, which
is most of the information
you're passing right now,
speech of course, is
through neural dynamics,
is through changing
patterns of activity.
Now we all know that,
whatever the clocks that
are within our brain, is
sometimes they're inaccurate.
So there's a mismatch
between objective time
and subjective time.
And this leads to
temporal illusions
or temporal distortions.
Everybody is familiar with, time
flies when you're having fun.
And to go back to a quote
from Henry James, which
was from his magnum opus,
"Principles of Psychology,"
written over 100 years ago.
He says, "In general,
a time filled
with varied and
interesting experiences
seems short in passing,
but long as we look back.
On the other hand, a tract
of time empty of experiences
seems long in passing,
but in retrospect short."
So some people refer to this
as the vacation paradox.
You're having fun in
Athens for the first day
and you're seeing a lot of
new sites, meeting new people,
and time seems to
fly by prospectively.
So as it's happening,
as it's playing out,
prospectively your
estimates of time
are only a short
amount of time has
elapsed, even
though it might have
been a long period of time.
But retrospectively,
as you look back,
that's not so much a timing
task but a memory task.
You're thinking back
of the number of items,
or you're influenced by the
number of items in memory.
So if you have a
filled day in which
a lot of interesting
things were happening,
you're going to have a lot
of memories of that event
and left with the
impression that it was
a long period of time elapsing.
Now in contrast, if
you're bored or anxious,
then as time is going
by prospectively,
you might overestimate
the amount of time.
It seems like a lot of
time has been going by.
So you're stuck at
the airport and you're
on a six hour wait
because of a plane delay,
and time is dragging.
You're bored out of your mind.
Retrospectively, when you
look back over your trip,
that's merely a blip in
your conscious experiences.
So because you know the Atlanta
bathroom is only so interesting
and it didn't store
too much information
about that wonderful experience
in your memory banks.
So we have this paradox
between prospective timing
and retrospective timing, which
in part influences our ability
to tell time.
Now everybody has
also known about cases
under extreme danger
or extreme stress
situations, in
which people report
time actually slowing
down or things
happening in slow motion.
And so this is a report
of a race car driver
whose car was thrown into the
air, spun around in the air.
He obviously survived and
later gives this report.
"It seemed like the
whole thing took forever.
Everything was in
slow motion and it
seemed to me like I was
a player on the stage
and could see myself tumbling
over and over in the car.
It was as though I
sat in the stands
and saw it all happening."
So here, obviously,
it's not only
their impression of the passage
of time that is being altered,
space as well.
I think this is probably best
described as an hallucination.
So this is an altered
state in which
our sense of time and sense
of body, sense of space,
has been dramatically altered.
So I think the mystery
here is not so much
what happens in these
states, but what
happens in a normal
state that gives us
our impression of
the passage of time.
Now this ability to
tell time and perceive
the passage of time, estimate
how much time has elapsed,
is not unique to
humans in any way.
All animals, or most
animals, certainly
have that sense of
the time of day,
they have a
circadian clock, they
can learn when food will
arrive, and so forth.
What is unique in
humans, however,
is probably our ability
to engage in what
we call Mental Time Travel.
So we can think about the
past and relive our memories
and re-experience things that
we have already experienced
and sort of study that.
We can learn, we can re-imagine
a conversation we had,
we can give it alternate
endings to test out
whether we should have said
something different or not.
But even more importantly,
we can imagine the future.
We can project ourselves
into the future
and simulate the
future in our heads.
And some people believe
that this is indeed
why consciousness evolved.
So consciousness is a way
to simulate the future.
And this is what
makes humans, humans.
The first person to carve
a knife or a weapon out
of an obsidian stone must
have had something in mind.
What am I going to use this for?
So this ability to
think about what
this will be used
for in the future
seems to evade the
ability of most animals.
So you take one of the
most important inventions
of humankind, agriculture,
it's a hard concept that we
take for granted.
I'm going to plant
something now and reap
its benefits that are
going to guarantee survival
a year from now.
This ability to link
cause and effect actions
across large delta T's,
long periods of time,
is very unique to humans.
I've always wondered if
humans are the only species
to have figured out the
relationship between sex
and pregnancy.
That's a fairly
long period of time.
Can other animals grasp
that relationship?
Because it spans periods
of weeks or months.
Now looking into the
future can be a bummer,
because the first humans
to really see the future
and grasp it, saw something
they probably didn't like.
And this might have been,
by the way, a good time
to invent religion, when you
first started understanding
what the future holds.
And I think this
point is beautifully
made by Jorge Luis Borges, "To
be immortal is commonplace;
except for man, all creatures
are immortal, for they
are ignorant of death."
So certainly seeing into
the long term future
is what characterizes
our species in many ways.
But it also does affect
our culture in many ways
and how we cope
with what we see.
Now just because humans
are uniquely able--
and I'm sorry, there's
a going to be one more
button I'm going to need pressed
over there for the next movie.
I didn't look far
enough into the future
to anticipate this, sorry.
So just because human
beings are uniquely
able to engage in
Mental Time Travel,
doesn't mean we're actually
particularly good at it.
And so learning to
delay gratification
and learning to withhold
immediate rewards for longer
term benefits is something our
species is uniquely able to do,
but it's also something
we struggle with.
So here's the gratuitous child,
cute baby video of the talk.
You can start that, please.
And this is the famous
marshmallow experiment.
Will that play?
Doesn't look like it's
going to play here.
We're probably OK.
Just try pressing Enter
or something there.
That's OK, we'll do without
the gratuitous video
of kids eating marshmallows.
So the marshmallow experiment,
as many of you probably know,
is an experiment in which they
get four or five-year-olds
and say, OK, here's
one marshmallow.
You can eat it now or you
can wait until I come back
and then you're going
to get two marshmallows.
And this ability to
delay gratification
is indeed part of what
it means to grow up,
to be able to withhold your
immediate gratification
for a later reward.
And these studies later showed,
these studies by Walter Mischel
at Stanford, that
started in the 70s,
and he later tracked down
many of these children.
And he found a correlation,
a weak correlation,
but a correlation nevertheless,
with their ability
to wait to withhold
gratification
at the young age with
later SAT scores.
So indeed there's many
pieces of evidence
that there's a
correlation between what
we call temporal discounting
or ability to postpone
or patients with
health issues as well.
So the major issue
there, of course,
is that much of what
we do is contingent
upon our understanding
that what we do now
has consequences in the future.
And going to school, saving
for retirement, exercising,
are all things that we take
for granted but are implicitly
contingent on our understanding
of temporal relationships,
of long term temporal
relationships.
But many of the problems we face
as individuals and as members
of society arise from not
doing that well enough,
Temporal Myopia.
So personal credit card debt,
exercising and eating healthy,
not saving enough
for retirement,
are things at the
individual level which
we struggle with in order
to balance our short term
gratification with
long term rewards.
At the more sort
of societal levels,
failure to adjust climate
change, under funded pension
plans, national debt, are things
that at the societal level
emerge in part
because of our failure
to take appropriate
actions in the present
to assure or guarantee a better
quality of life or health
in the future.
Now humans, as I
said, are uniquely
able to think about
the long term future.
So how did that come about?
What's unique about the human
brain that gives us the ability
to understand the fundamental
difference between the past,
present, and future and
to plan for months, years,
or even decades ahead?
So some people have argued
that we do that in part
because of our ability
to talk and use language.
and our brain's
ability to co-opt
to the parts of the brain that
are used to understand space.
The idea is that there's areas
in the brains of most mammals
that allow them to navigate
and understand space,
in a manner of speaking.
And maybe the human brain
co-opted those same structures
to allow us to understand time.
And one argument
in favor of this
is that a lot of the
ways we talk about time
is by using spatial metaphors.
So I might say,
it was a long day,
or I'm looking
forward to the clips.
Or you're thinking, I hope
this talk ends shortly.
So we're using spatial
metaphors to talk about time.
This idea of the
spatialization of time
is really one of the main
ways we talk and discuss
and understand time.
And another way
to exemplify this
is with what we call
the Wednesday question.
So I'll say, our
Wednesday meeting
was moved forward two days.
What day is our meeting on?
On Monday, or Friday?
So there's no right
or wrong answer there,
but it does reflect two
different perspectives
we have about time.
So if you view time
as sort of fixed
and you're the one walking
through time and you're moving,
then you'd say you
move something forward
and from Wednesday it
might go to Friday.
That's sort of what we call
an ego moving perspective.
But if we have a time
moving perspective,
you're probably in the Monday
group in which you're static
and time is like a river
flowing towards you
and then the meeting
would be on Monday.
So there's these two
different perspectives
that people have about time.
And they just reflect
that ambiguity
of language and the fact
that we spatialize time
within our brains.
Now this idea of the
spatialization of time,
that time is laid
out in space, is
very deep in the
philosophical literature,
as well as in physics,
because there's
sort of two diverging theories
as to the true nature of time.
One is precisely this, that time
is a dimension much like space.
So this is called eternalism.
Under eternalism, the past,
the present, and the future
are all equally real.
Now is perfectly arbitrary.
Now is as arbitrary as here.
Just like here is a perfectly
valid point in space to be,
I'm perfectly fine with
you being over there.
In time, now is arbitrary and
I should be perfectly fine.
In eternalism, now is
perfectly arbitrary
and other versions of me
or other versions of you,
if you will, are at past
moments or present moments.
So everything is equally real.
And under presentism,
in contrast, and this
is sort of the more
intuitive sense we have,
in that only the
present is real.
So the past was real,
some configuration
of the universe that we call
past and now exists only
in our memories, was real.
The present is real.
And the future, or
some configuration
of the universe at
some future point,
will become real based on
what's happening in the present.
So of course, eternalism sort
of justifies a talk or a debate
about whether time
travel is possible.
It has nothing do with the
physics of time travel,
whether you can
actually do it or not,
but eternalism justifies the
debate because at least there's
moments in time that exist
that you could potentially
try to travel to.
Under presentism the
talk of time travel
is a moot point because
there's nowhere to go,
or there's no when to
go, to be more precise.
Now eternalism is
sort of, to the degree
that there is a standard view in
physics, is the standard view.
And this is in part because
of Einstein's theory
of special relativity.
So let me just try to
convey, I find presentism
to be much more intuitive.
I think it's more consistent
with our experience.
But we believe in eternalism,
at least in the physical sense,
for very good reasons.
So let me try to convey
those reasons, or one
of those reasons.
So to do this, let me go
over a thought experiment,
an Einsteinian thought
experiment, in which
we have the following setup.
We have an observer on a
stationary platform and a train
going by at a ludicrously,
impossibly fast speed of 2/3
the speed of light, 0.67
times the speed of light.
There's an individual in the
middle of the train that's
shooting these space-age
bullets towards the front
and the back of the train.
Now if you're this
individual, it
doesn't matter, because
of the laws of physics
and relativity, that
you're moving or not.
So you're going to shoot
the bullet forward and shoot
the bullet backwards
and those bullets
have to travel the same
distance at the same speed.
So this pane of glass will
break at the same time
as that pane of glass.
So this person should observe
that pane of glass breaking
at the same time
as this person was.
Now here you're the
observer and you're
going to see the train
traveling at a high speed.
You're going to see
this bullet traveling
in the opposite direction
at the same speed.
So this bullet will
have speed zero,
it will have velocity zero.
So basically, this bullet
will standing in mid-air
as the back of the train
runs into the bullet.
OK, that's pretty
straightforward.
Now this forward
bullet should be
going at the speed of the bullet
plus the speed of the train.
Now the speed of the bullet
is 2/3 the speed of light,
the speed of the train is
2/3 the speed of light.
So the sum of those is 1.3
times the speed of light.
That's a no-no, right?
We can't go faster than
the speed of light,
that's what Einstein told us.
So there's something goofy
that's going to happen here.
This bullet can't
be traveling as fast
as it needs to be going to
break this pane of glass
at the same time.
So we see the bullet in motion
approaching the panes of glass.
And the person on the train
will observe both panes breaking
at the same time, they'll
be breaking simultaneously.
But the person on the
stationary platform
will not see that happen.
And it has nothing
to do with delays
or the time it takes information
to get from here to there.
So it is just based on all
those adjustments and delays
being taken into account.
So this person will observe
a different reality.
While this person has a reality
in which both panes of glass
break at the same time,
for this person's reality,
there will be a moment in
time where this is broken,
but that is not.
So this is taken as
an argument, this lack
of absolute
simultaneity is taken
as an argument for the block
universe, or for eternalism.
Why is that?
So let me give it again,
run that through you
with this example here.
So let's look at this sort
of mini block universe
with four dimensions.
But we're going to only plot
two, instead of the three
spatial dimensions
we only have one,
and we have this
temporal dimension.
So for the person
on the train, this
is their plane of simultaneity.
There's a moment where
both panes of glass
at the back of the train and
at the front of the train
are both intact.
There's another moment in
exactly the same moment where
both panes of glass break.
Then there'll be
another moment in time
where both panes of
glass are already broken.
So these are the
planes of simultaneity
for the person on the train.
In reality, the person on the
platform is, in our analogy,
not moving, which is the same
thing as from the perspective
of the person on the train.
The person on the
platform is moving
in the opposite direction.
So just for reasons here,
this might be a bit easier
to explain that way.
So the person on
the platform is sort
of traveling in the
opposite direction
of the person on the train.
Now these planes of
simultaneity don't match up
for the person on the platform.
So the plane of simultaneity,
Einstein's theory
of special relativity
tells us that these moments
will be the same on
this person's clock.
So there will be a moment where
the front pain is not broken
and the back one is.
So the point is that it's as
if the universe, everything
that can happen has
already happened.
And the reason some
things appear simultaneous
for one person and
not for another
is a question of perspective.
So here the idea is, from
this person's perspective,
these events are aligned,
but not for this person.
So this is one of the arguments
for eternalism or the block
universe.
Now there's a clash here, right?
If this is true, it sort
of leaves our impression
of the flow of time
as an illusion.
Because if everything
has already happened,
the clear subjective
feeling that time is flowing
would seem that it has to be an
illusion, in a certain sense.
And physicists have
long been aware of this.
So this is a quote
from Roger Penrose,
"It seems to me that there
are severe discrepancies
between what we
consciously feel,
concerning the flow
of time, and what
our theories assert about the
reality of the physical world."
Here's another good
quote by Herman Veil,
a physicist from the mid 1900s.
"The objective world simply
is, it does not happen.
Only to the gaze of
my consciousness,
crawling upward along the
world line of my body,
does a section of the
world come to life
as a fleeting image
in space which
continuously changes in time."
So they're getting to this
issue that the flow of time
must be an illusion.
So this severely clashes with
the neuroscience of time.
And it clearly feels that the
subjective experience of time
is flowing by.
Now the question is if this is
consistent with our experience
of consciousness.
Now we don't really
know what consciousness
is so this is a very
difficult question to address.
But consciousness
probably isn't what
it seems to be, in the
sense that it seems
to be providing a linear
narrative of what's happening
in the world around us.
Rather, the
unconscious mind seems
to be creating this
narrative in chunks
and then feeding this
into the conscious mind,
or creating conscious
mind, if you will,
to create a convenient and
apparent flow of what's
happening.
So there's a couple of
illusions that show this.
It's a bit of a hard
concept to explain.
But let me just try to give
you a quick example here.
I'm going to say two
sentences and just
pay attention to the
meaning of the sentences.
So the first sentence
is, the mouse pad
was beside the computer.
The second sentence,
the mouse was hungry.
So in both those sentences,
the meaning of the word mouse
was very different, right?
So I think you're
able to understand
that in the first case
the mouse referred
to an object, the
computer mouse pad.
And the second to a rodent.
But the meaning of
mouse could only
be determined by the
words that came after.
You cannot possibly interpret
that sentence in real time.
The mouse pad or the
mouse was hungry.
So what comes after has to
influence your interpretation
of what came before.
So this is one of
the lines of evidence
that suggests that our
conscious experience is not
so much a continuous
linear flow of the world
around us, but of a
creation that is generated
and sort of fits in bursts of
the interpretation of what's
happening around us.
So it may be the case that our
understanding of consciousness
may or may not be compatible
with the standard view
in physics.
I think Steven Pinker was
hinting at this when he stated,
"Matter is extended in space,
but consciousness exists
in time as surely as it proceeds
from 'I think' to 'I am.'"
So we have to decide--
and I think physicists
and neuroscientists
have to collaborate more
to decide if we should view
our subjective sense
of the passage of time
as an empirical observation
about the universe, one that
has to be explained by physics.
Or if it's an illusion
in the deepest
sense of the world,
and thus one that
doesn't have to be
explained by physics,
but then has to be
explained by neuroscience.
How does the brain generate the
conscious, subjective feeling
of something that
has no correlate
in the physical world, that
is, of the flow of time?
Now to address
these questions, I
think we have a long way to go.
And neuroscience is
a very unique field.
Neuroscience a unique
field in all of sciences
because neuroscience
is the only field
in which the organ, or
the thing being studied,
is also doing the studying.
And this raises a couple
of potential concerns.
Not least of which, well,
is that even possible?
Can something understand itself?
It's of course way too early
to answer that question.
But as scientific fields
evolve, as they mature,
part of that
maturation process is
to progressively embrace time.
You look at what I would
consider the first field
of modern science, geometry.
Geometry is formalized by
Euclid 2,300 years ago,
it was highly influential
and transformative.
But why was it the
first field of science?
Well, it was the
first field of science
because science is easier
if you can ignore time.
That's what geometry is, right?
Geometry is the study
of space and objects
that don't change in time.
It was only around
2,000 years after Euclid
when people, such as
Galileo and Newton
came along, and fully integrated
time and dynamics into physics.
Same thing in biology.
If you think about biology, up
until 1700s, most of the 1800s,
it was largely taxonomic
and fairly static.
And then Darwin, playing
the role of Galileo,
said, hey, species are dynamic.
They change, they adapt,
they evolve in time.
I think neuroscience is only
reaching this renaissance
now where it's fully
beginning to embrace time.
And realize that the brain is,
in a sense, a temporal organ.
It's a time machine,
if you will.
It tells time, it remembers
the past to predict the future,
it allows us to
mentally time travel,
and creates the subjective
sense of the flow of time.
So elucidating how the brain
tells time, represents,
and conceptualizes time is
critical to understanding
the human mind and the
nature of consciousness.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
CARL: We'd like to answer
questions, if that's OK here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I have
two questions over here.
The first question
is about your claim
that humans are
unique in the sense
that we can foresee the future.
But there has been
a lot of studies,
like in monkeys, where
they can plan for the day,
what they are going to do.
That they wake up every morning
and they go and get some figs.
If they don't go
for the figs, they
will just stay awake later.
So it's kind of a weak
argument what you just made.
In what sense do you--
DEAN BUONOMANO: I think, so
it's called mental time travel.
And the debate about
whether other animals
can engage in mental time
travel is an active one.
What there's no debate
about is the extent
to which humans can engage
in mental time travel.
So no other animal can
talk about plans five years
in the future because no other
animals can conceive or can
communicate about that.
But interestingly,
the best animal data
on the possibility of mental
time travel in animals
is not from monkeys.
So the monkeys data
is fairly debated.
The major test people
use there is if monkeys
can learn to use money.
Because money is something
that implicitly requires--
This has no value.
This has no value, right?
Paper has no value.
It only has value because
I assume that in the future
I can exchange it
for something better.
So they try to teach monkeys,
apes, great apes, to use money
by changing for tokens.
And they can sort
of get it to hang,
but this is highly debated.
So that data is
still controversial.
But the best data
actually comes from birds.
And there's corvids, scrub
jays, that the best argument
comes from.
They can seem to,
if they're always
exposed to one part
of their aviary
in the morning and one
part in the afternoon,
they seem that
they can plan ahead
by putting the food in the
part of the morning aviary
and not in the afternoon aviary.
So this is an active
field to debate.
But part of the debate
is just one of extent.
And humans clearly can cross
years and centuries that other
animals can't.
AUDIENCE: OK,
another question, you
were mentioning
this kind of view
between the physical
explanation and
the psychological explanation of
where we stand with time as we
move forward.
But there is like
a physical sense
where you can put
an arrow of time
and this [INAUDIBLE]
entropy, like [INAUDIBLE].
So there is like an
objective physical sense
that you can say that the pace
of time that moves forward.
It's not an acknowledgement.
DEAN BUONOMANO: So in
the block universe,
everything is already laid out.
But there's still
an arrow of time
because there's a forward
arrow in which things go
one way and not the other way.
As you probably know, the laws
of physics are time asymmetric.
You can run Newton's equations
or Einstein's equations or even
Schrodinger's equation
forwards or backwards.
There's no time.
So the typical explanation
to address the arrow of time
is, as you brought up,
the entropic arrow,
that entropy increases.
Now entropy by itself
doesn't explain the arrow.
What it does is just say
it provides an asymmetry.
The real explanation
comes from the fact
that the universe
seems to have started
in a state of low entropy and
from there it can only go up.
But the tricky
thing about entropy
is if I say there's a
state of medium entropy
here, that predicts
that the next time step
it should be higher.
But if you think
about it, it also
predicts that the previous
time step should be higher.
So the entropic
arrow is sometimes
called a bi-directional
arrow that doesn't explain
the arrow of time by itself.
It needs to be coupled with
an assumption about a lower
initial state.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: So first
of all, and I'm not
saying this to impress
anyone, but I'm an atheist.
But when I look at the
eternalism worldview, the block
world, you know we can look at
a person as a baby and a person
as an adult. And practically
all or all cells of their body
have since died
and been replaced.
And that's a topic in itself,
like what makes me, me.
Like why do I feel like--
But if I look at the block
universe, as you depicted it,
and say, OK, space and
time is all there is
and they all exist
already, then it
brings about a
philosophical question
of what links the slice where
I was a baby and the slice
where I'm an adult to
create a consciousness that
views both as the same thing.
Right, so it almost suggests
an additional layer.
No?
DEAN BUONOMANO: I don't know.
I think the question
of consciousness
is perplexing either way.
Whether what makes
you, you or makes me,
me and what
consciousness is, I think
that's a dilemma
challenge to science,
whether you're
participating, whether you
subscribe to the eternalist view
or the presentist view, right?
Consciousness we can't
explain either way.
But I think there's a
further challenge posed
by the eternalist view when
it comes to consciousness.
In terms of if things
aren't flowing, changing
in a dynamic fashion, why do
we have this clear, distinct
feeling?
And more importantly, what's
the evolutionary function
of feeling time change
if there is no correlate
with the actual universe?
It's not like something,
we perceive color, right?
Color is a creation of
the human mind, right?
Because there's no color
in the physical world.
There's wavelengths of
electromagnetic radiation.
We interpret that as color, but
that has a very strong adaptive
value.
So there's a correlation there.
So the question is if we
see, if we feel time flowing,
but it actually doesn't,
what's that function
from an evolutionary
perspective?
And I think that's a
mystery that we'll probably
have for a while.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks for coming.
So what's the difference
between the mental time
travel and, like, fantasy?
You know, like telling myself
a story about the future?
What I mean is, like an example
is I could tell myself a story
that I will go to the store
later and it will be open.
But that might not be so.
So is there a probability
element wrapped up in there?
DEAN BUONOMANO: I
think the question,
an interesting question,
is could we even
have stories if we couldn't
have mental time travel?
Can other animals have
stories, and whether that story
takes place in the future
or the present or the past?
Later on I'm going
to go to the museum.
And so is that a story, is that
a plan, or is that a fiction?
So what makes humans
unique, I believe,
is that what makes us
creative is this fine line
between stories and reality.
So if I'm primitive
man and it's a story,
oh I wish I could
hunt down a mammoth.
Is that a story?
But then you're thinking,
well, if I had a weapon,
maybe I could.
So this marriage of the
stories and reality I think
is probably what's driving
much of our technology
and creativity.
It is this very delicate balance
between getting the stories
just so that it
sounds like fiction,
but it's fiction we can
create in the future.
AUDIENCE: Sure,
yeah, I would just
say we're almost always wrong.
DEAN BUONOMANO: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Until we've
seen a repeatable path,
if that makes sense.
DEAN BUONOMANO: I certainly feel
that I'm almost always wrong.
I assume [INAUDIBLE]
people are often right.
But yeah, there's trial
and error and stochasticity
in there, absolutely.
And we can't know in advance.
So if the future
has been laid out,
clearly we don't
have access to it.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
DEAN BUONOMANO: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Hello, Thanks so much.
This is great.
DEAN BUONOMANO: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Are you familiar
with Donald Hoffman?
DEAN BUONOMANO: No
AUDIENCE: He's a
physicist philosopher.
He's got interesting
theories about consciousness.
Well I'm probably going
to butcher his theory,
but I think, essentially,
it's that consciousness
is the base of reality
and everything else
is like on top of it.
So he claims to have
proven that, what is it,
like everything we
know, everything we see
is just based on, is
just to be reconstructed.
Because it was
evolutionarily adaptable
it was like a good thing for us.
Do you think time could be
something similar to that?
DEAN BUONOMANO: So there's
this very interesting debate
about whether time--
So some fields or
hypotheses in physics
are trying to get rid of time,
so say that time doesn't exist.
And what this means is that
time is not a property.
They're not saying that time,
clock time, doesn't exist.
What they're saying is that time
isn't a fundamental property
of the universe, it's not
like energy or matter,
and that time is simply an
abstraction, a creation,
of the human mind.
The way Ernst Mach put this
is, it's utterly impossible
to measure change
by time because time
is an abstraction at which we
arrive at by measuring change.
And that's indeed
what clocks do.
All clocks are are just
some weights, some device,
that conveniently
standardizes change,
whether that change is the
swing of a pendulum or a quartz
crystal.
So the subjective
feeling of time,
I think I've sort of already
expressed, it's unknown.
But the concept of
time, I do like the idea
that it's an
abstraction that we've
created that's
incredibly useful to help
us understand the universe
and make sense of the world.
But it's not a fundamental
property of physics.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
this talk, by the way.
DEAN BUONOMANO: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I had some
questions about your thoughts
on how our relative
conceptions of time
are limited by physical
dendrites, axons,
physical barriers.
So in a world where
we are able to create
artificial intelligence,
or even potentially upload
our own consciousness, or
replicate our consciousness,
in a world which isn't limited
by dendrites and axons,
what are your thoughts
on being able to extend
our concepts of time because
of those physical barriers
removed?
Or slowing down.
So a real person is
existing, there's
an AI which experiences
1,000 years of time
because they're able to
process information faster.
DEAN BUONOMANO: There's
a couple of issues there.
So those are deep questions.
One is the hardware
question, right?
Is consciousness in our
subjective experience
of time hardware dependent,
hardware limited?
Can you create AIs
that have consciousness
totally equivalent to ours?
So that's a question
that, of course,
nobody knows the answer to.
As a materialist,
I certainly believe
there's no reason
that consciousness
has to be hardware limited.
Now that question, however,
is different from the question
of speed of processing.
So this question
of sampling rate
in which the speed of processing
is ultimately independent
of our notion of
the passage of time.
You're processing signals
coming from my speech.
You're doing that
right now that are far
beyond your
subjective experience
of the passage of time.
So the brain clearly
processes things
that are happening
very quickly like this,
that's micro-seconds.
Your brain detects that.
So even though they're
made of neurons,
it's an incredible feat, right?
Neurons have a time constant
of maybe an action potential.
So if you we're going to give
it a computer clock rate,
you'd probably give
it a kilohertz instead
of a couple of hundred
gigahertz, for example.
So that time level
of processing is
different from the time level
of subjective experiences.
Now, nobody knows the
answer to the question
of whether an AI
would be able to have
these temporal distortions
of conscious experiences
like you or I have.
But I think there's, in a
way it's a wrong question.
I think the mystery
is not so much
how time comes to be distorted
in extreme cases of time
dilation or time
compression, but what
our normal sense of time is.
And I view this as just the
flexibility of consciousness.
You can be conscious of
a short period of time
or a long period of time.
That's just a
conscious state, it's
just a flavor of
consciousness, just
like pain or pleasure or color.
So I think that
when we understand
the nature of
consciousness, the question
of whether it
seems long or short
will be sort of a minor
issue along those lines.
Because I think what we
perceive is a bit arbitrary.
CARL: Just a quick note, we're
a bit over 2:00 PM, so let's not
add more questions.
If you're already in
line, ask your questions.
AUDIENCE: OK, I
think you'll hear.
I want to ask about,
what is the difference
or are they the same thing for
the things like retrospective
thinking and the
autobiographic memory?
Or the retrospective thinking is
about a general loss of memory
or just things about
myself in the past?
DEAN BUONOMANO: Yes
that's a good question.
So autobiographical
memory, or episodic memory,
is about events in our own life.
And that's tightly coupled
to how we retrospectively
perceive time.
So if there's a
period of time which
you have a rich
autobiographical memory,
I did this, this, this
this, this and this,
that's likely to elicit
a long estimate of time.
Whereas if you don't have
any events in memory,
that's a short period of time.
The extreme example of this
is somebody who has amnesia.
So you can imagine if
somebody has no ability
to form new episodic memories
or autobiographical memories,
how could they even estimate
that time has elapsed?
So there's this very
touching, poignant case
of a British man
called Clive Waring.
And maybe some of you
have seen specials on him.
But he has terrible
anterograde amnesia
and he seems to be
locked into the present.
There's a story where he's
writing in his diary 9:00 AM,
I just woke up.
9:30, now I'm awake
for the first time.
10 o'clock, now I'm really
awake for the first time.
Because if you don't
have that memory, how can
how much time has elapsed?
So clearly, retrospectively,
time and memory
are tightly coupled.
AUDIENCE: So as you said, all
of our time keeping devices
rely on oscillators,
or rely on some kind
of notion of periodicity.
And so I guess my
question is if you
look at an oscillation
or a sine wave
or any sort of any
sort of phenomenon
that you can
understand that way,
there's a notion
of symmetry that's
really important,
that you could be
at one point in this
oscillation or you
can be at the exact same
point in another period later.
And so it gives you that
eternal perspective.
What if that didn't exist?
So how would we measure
time if we didn't
have this sort of repeatable--
DEAN BUONOMANO: You mean
man-made time, right?
Clock time, you mean?
AUDIENCE: Well I guess
what I'm asking is,
like, is there something
fundamental about the idea
of periodicity?
How would we measure time
if there wasn't something
that was symmetric that we
could always kind of start back
at that point?
DEAN BUONOMANO: So
no, I don't think so.
I think it's just reproducibly.
You can measure time
by an hour glass,
it's something that's
doesn't have to be periodic.
So I think man-made clocks
rely on this mechanism
because it's an incredibly
useful symmetric one.
And the best way to do
something continuously
is with something
that's periodic.
But you need some
sophisticated counter,
and that was really
the main problem.
But even if you
look at something
like planetary motion, you
can tell the time of year
by looking at the
positions of the planets.
AUDIENCE: Well, right,
that's sort of my point.
So even with an hourglass,
you could turn it over.
There's like the resetting.
DEAN BUONOMANO: You can,
but you don't have to.
You can, but you
don't have to, right?
You could have a
non-periodic hourglass.
So I think periodicity is
something that, in our minds,
because of the success
of man-made clocks,
is something we naturally
think of as an ideal way
to tell time.
And it probably is.
But interestingly,
and I think there's
a downside to that,
which is people
spent a bit too
much time looking
for those oscillators
encounters in the brain.
And I think that threw
the field off a bit
because that's probably not
how the brain tells time.
Yes, the brain has
oscillators, but it
doesn't seem to have many
oscillator counter systems.
So I think these metaphors
we use in the external world
sometimes can put us back
a bit when we're overly
influenced by them.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DEAN BUONOMANO: Thank you.
CARL: Thanks
everybody for coming.
And thanks, Dean.
DEAN BUONOMANO: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]